i am pleased to announce that i am very
confident
every county in the state of nevada will
be able to fully reopen at 100
capacity by june 1st
a huge step forward in getting las vegas
and the rest of nevada back on track
thanks for joining us at 11 i'm denise
valdez and i'm brian loftis tonight
governor sysolak announcing his goal to
have all of the state
fully reopened by the first of june but
it will be up to local jurisdictions
beginning next month
now we have team coverage from around
the valley tonight
to hear from local restaurants and how
our major sports teams
are taking to the news but we start on
the strip tonight where orco mana looked
at the impact these changes will have
orco denise and brian the las vegas
strip has seen a lot of changes over the
past 13 months
casinos theaters and businesses have all
had to make major changes
because of capacity limits so many are
excited at the possibility
of reaching full capacity soon
there's nothing like live performance
the soul juice band's residency at
mandalay bay closed last year due to
covet 19 concerns
lead singer david tatlock says the
theater still hasn't opened because of
limited capacities
it's difficult to even make a profit
but now governor steve says a lack's
goal is for all nevada counties to get
to 100 percent capacity by june 1st
including casinos and venues on the las
vegas strip tatlock says that's music to
his ears
it's a great opportunity for everybody
to get back to work especially
in a city like ours that thrives on
large gatherings of people
the governor saying his plan holds
promise the path forward
to bringing back our state economy
helping our small businesses
bringing back conventions and getting
nevadans back to work
it's such a relief pam howitt owns local
catering company divine events which
relies on convention business
she says increased capacities means more
conventions could be on their way
world of concrete already set for early
june seeing those
come back and roll the concrete i'm sure
there's going to be some
possibilities there as well full
capacity by june 1st is tentative
depending on our coronavirus situation
tourists are split on the idea that will
be premature judgment on my part because
i don't know how things going to be on
may 1st as long as
the vaccination is given out more then
it should be safe to do that
locals are just hoping for the best
we're really looking forward to our
chance to get back
now governor sislek is also making it
clear that just because he wants
capacities to go up
that does not mean we should let our
guard down social distancing and mask
wearing
will still be a top priority live in the
newsroom tonight workout mana 8 news now